Joshua Jordan: The Fabrication Lab at Columbia
architecture has been around since the
1970s when it started as an entirely
student democratic experiment. So over
time we've come together and it's
something that is both sort of run in
the sense that students staff and work
in this space and keep it running along
with me in that we have a sort of an
overall sense and conversation among the
faculty and the students about what this
place should be and what machines we should have
One of the big changes that
I've made here at this school is to kind
of rethink making at this school and
expand our fabrication lab to really
become a makerspace. This is a very
interesting moment where students and
faculty are hybridizing what we call the
analog and the digital so it's not just
about fetishizing the digital and being
cutting-edge and having million-dollar
robots and doing research but really
bringing together old ways of thinking -
making and casting and and and using
wood and with the highest technology of
3D printing and and milling and so
there's a lot of kind of originality
that's coming out of that hybridizing.
The first day of classes I was really
interested in building a set of shelves
for our apartment and I think that
dialogue really got me feeling invested
in the space knowing that it was a place
that was open to anybody to pursue
creative projects whether it was related
to a studio or their classes and I think
what I loved so much about how the shop
has been evolving over the past couple
of years is that it's really been open
to embracing people's interests whenever
someone has a project that we don't have
a tool for will order the tool... it's been
expanding a lot from just being a general woodshop.
One of the things that
we've tried to do here in the
fabrication lab is be as
interdisciplinary as possible. We have at
least five different programs working
within the Graduate School here and one
of our big missions and sort of reboot
of the shop is to find a way for them
all to get as much mileage and sort of
innovation out of the space as possible.
On the operational end what we've done
is reconfigure our sort of training and
access technique to be as agnostic as
possible to levels of experience that
people have coming in. So we make our
training as teachable to historic
preservation as we do to urban design as
we do to architecture so everybody
learns the sort of same concepts in the
beginning and then they can sort of
perform together and materials in the
shop to the same level and then when
people see what each other are working
on that is not necessarily something
that they might normally work on there's
an instant conversation that just
proliferate and explodes as a student
you have all these resources especially
for the last two years I Josh really
makes this place very very reachable like
accessible to students and you can come
here like 24/7 and you can build
whatever you want here just with your
materials so they really make the like
prices super cheap, like if you want to
depend as where you need to spend a lot
more money. when we think of a more
creative and sustainable world for the
future you know it's important that we
think where the materials come from and
how do we hybridize them and how we
think of reusing waste in original ways
and so it's much more than just kind of
fabrication is thinking through the
lifecycle of materials and that really
starts in the makerspace